お釈迦さんの後ろから行くんです
ブッダから学ぶ大西洋の道
はい 成功ばかり気にする無知な人は無視する
学ぶ道ということ これよく覚えておいてください
学ぶ道という 何といいますか
用語なんです これすごい意味があるんです
で すごいというか 仏教から見れば
ただ単に人生は学ぶ道であるべきなんです
ただそれだけ 何のために生きるのかとか
そんなことどうでもいい
妄想はどうでもいいんですよ
とにかく学ぶと では中身に入ります
計画だけでは計画だけでは決してうまくいかないんですね
想定外のことは必ず起こるんです
計画を立てても もう環境と時間違いますからね
計画にしがみつくと 予想外の変化に適応できない
実行中止になるんです
それで計画を立てて実行すると
計画が過去のもので 実行は将来やっていることで
将来は時間 空間 全部変わってるし
だから予想外のことは起こるんです
計画にしがみつくと 予想外のことを起きたらもう計画中止ですね
だから人間の頭が悪いことが
認めて社会 私じゃないんです
皆様が生きている社会がそれを認めて
この悪さはどのように守ってあげようかと思って
例えばマクドナルドでバイトをやっていると
ハンバーガーはどのように組み立てるかということは全部写真で
あのカウンターの裏側は貼ってあるんです
で 他のインスタント食品を売っているところではどこでも同じなんです
で それを見ながらやればいいんで
自分で何にも考える必要はないんです
全部パッケージでできてますからね
これ開けて これは電子レンジでも 3 秒
10 秒回してとか それも時間調整する必要もないんです
書いてます なになにハンバーガーの場合はこれと
なければこれこれってそのそのボタンを押せばいいという
だから計画でしょう 精密な計画で
精密なマニュアルで もうちょっとだけでもよって変化はできません
できません だからそれで人間としては生きてないでしょ？ロボットでしょ
だからみんな好きなんですね
ロボット化 すべて整理整頓してあって
この決まり通りに動けばいいという生き方はね
ということで 我々は自分の無知を宝物ごとく守っているんです
自由思想の人にとってはものすごい生きづらいんです
新しく物事を考える人にとっては
もうもう流産の風呂に入れたような感じなんです
それで仏教的な計画は何も三面鏡ですね
全部見ているんです  1 具体的に
具体的に実践可能な範囲で計画を立てる
いずれも実践実行できるかないか
そこをすごく大事に考えなくちゃいけないんです
２は実行中 常に調整をし続ける
計画を立てる時でも 具体性が大事にして
実行できるかないかということはすごい大事に考えちゃうともうかなりうまくいきますよ
うまくいくんだけど 実行中でもいつでも
何て言いますか 調整するんです
マニュアルで行こうとは思わないんです
マニュアルで行くんだけど
微妙に微妙に微妙に調整して調整して持っていくんです
3目的に達してから反省をする
目的にあった俺がやったぞということじゃなくて
それでよかったのかと
それはそれによって有意義なことに挑戦することになれるんです
この成功したところで反省しないんだから
まあ何でもいいんだからやる羽目になっちゃいます
だから成功が有意義か無意味かと
成功してからも反省するという
このこの 3つの側面があります
はい 時には頭が良くてもということで
よく考えているからといってうまくいくはずはありません
思考はループばかりで
ループばかりで執着点がないのは普通です
はい 考えるときは固定概念
感情などをなくす 常に思考は有効か否か
実効的か否かというガイドラインから外れないようにする
だから思考はいくらでもということではなくて
あるガイドラインを決めて
その中で持っていかなくちゃいけないんです
だから 日本の社会では
人の行動をすごく狭くして
もう考えることさえももう禁止されていることとは違います
ちゃんと照準感が握ってから思考するという
はい 自と他に対する慈しみを大事にする
考える場合でも いつでも自分に対する慈しみと他人に対する慈しみだけは忘れとなら
それはもう唯一の守りなんです
世界に何一つも我々を守ってくれるものはない
何の呪文も 何の神も自分を守ってくれません
たった慈しみだけ自分を守ってくれます
不幸にならないように
だから考える人が 例えば妄想して病気になっている人って結構いるでしょ
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 自己嫌悪
落ち込み そればっかしの妄想なんですよ
妄想をやめられないんだったら
そこをちょこっと慈しみに変えるの
学校に行きたくないではなくて
お母さんが困っているでしょうねとかね
俺が学校に行ってよく勉強すればお母さん喜ぶでしょうとかね
お父さんが困っているでしょうねとか
私は何もできなくて もう大人になっても家にいるようになっちゃうとね
やっぱり大事に育ててくれた母親に
父親に対して負担でしょうと
そういう風に妄想すればどうですかね
そんな妄想したければ
そういうのは問題解決しますよ
守られます だから思考する場合は
計画を考えようか 学問のことを考えようか
ただふざけて遊びのことを考えようか
どうでもいいんだけど
慈しみって という守りを
巨大な守り 究極の守りだけは外してはならないのです